bonsoir à tous nous sommes le mardi à 6
septembre merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
tout de suite on commence avec les
titres la ligne 18 du grand paris
express ne passera pas sous le quartier
de la boissière un voisin nouveau retenu
la décision est officielle
un soulagement pour les habitants la
région vient au secours à des
agriculteurs touchés par des inondations
puis par la sécheresse cette année ils
vont obtenir des compensations
financières pour pallier leurs pertes
et enfin nous parlerons de la fin des
travaux de la médiathèque du canal et du
musée de la ville à montigny le
bretonneux et équipe s'installe avant
d'accueillir à nouveau les usagers le
point sur les nouveautés chiant et après
les inondations du mois de mai et la
sécheresse du mois de juin le monde
agricole francilien a connu de
nombreuses perturbations de nombreuses
structures d'île de france ont vu leurs
récoltes fortement à diminuer pour cette
année 2016 et les conséquences
pourraient se faire ressentir la région
ile de france a décidé d'apporter une
aide à la profession valérie pécresse la
présidente de la région s'est rendu la
semaine dernière dans une exploitation
yvelinoise je propose de regardez ce
reportage signé mélanie pauli 2 500 à
600 euros par hectare des pertes
catastrophiques selon les agriculteurs
franciliens
la récolte 2016 et inédite mercredi 31
août la présidente de la région ile de
france a présenté un dispositif de
soutien de plus de 6 millions d'euros
il faut être à leurs côtés il faut les
aider il faut être là et la mesure qui
nous ont proposés
est une mesure intelligente parce que
l'idée c'est d'éviter l'effet domino
aujourd'hui ils ont créé mauvaise
récolte 6 m
les mauvaises langues qu'ils ont récolté
cette année ils ont une mairie colle
encore pire donc on va travailler sur la
qualité des semences on va aider à
acheter des bonnes semences pour que la
récolte soit meilleur l'année prochaine
les grains de blé porte les stigmates
des mauvaises conditions climatiques de
ces derniers mois moins coloré plus
petit la récolte de lucien va les
céréaliers yvelinois a été fortement
touchée lors de la moisson en récoltant
le grain on s'est aperçu que les épis
été formé mais qui avait rien dedans
c'est à dire en épluchant un épi de blé
on s'est retrouvé avec 400 grain normaux
et tout le reste des des petits grains
ou ratatiner
malade une année normale en blé jeu
je suis en une moyenne de 80 85 quintaux
et
là je me retrouve
sur un rendement de 40 40 quintaux les
plus anciens d'entre nous nos parents
nos grands parents n'ont jamais connu
cette situation il était resté gravé
l'année 76 dans les mémoires qui était
une année de sécheresse celle ci qui
avait un pacte et durement les
rendements mais une année 2016 comme ça
qui impacte avec des niveaux de
rendement / 2d chiffre d'affaires divisé
par deux et c'est quelque chose qu'on
n'a jamais connu le dispositif actuel
s'ajoutent aux millions d'euros déjà
débloqués par la région en soutien aux
agriculteurs touchés par les inondations
et agriculture toujours ces dernières
semaines vous avez beaucoup entendu
parler de la crise du lait l'initiative
dont nous allons vous parler vise
justement à trouver des solutions à ce
problème c'est le lait d'île de france
ils arrivent sur le marché et provient
de trois ferme installée dans les
yvelines une démarche locale et qui se
veut plus responsable regardez ils en
sont très fiers seul et d'île de france
c'est le leur c'est aussi une aventure
inédite intermarché s'est associé avec
trois fermes yvelinoise viltain à jouy
en josas la ferme de bissy abonnés les
la ferme de thiverval grignon pour
distribuer et produire le lait d'île de
france sacrée aussi je dirais une valeur
ajoutée sur l'anglais de façon à ce que
nos entreprises puissent
vivre continuer à gagner de l'argent
pour continuer à investir et voir
continuer à se développer
on espère retrouver déjà un souffle de
trésorerie clairement et puis bah c'est
faire connaître
notre ferme notre production alors notre
et nous ferme d'ailleurs ce qu'on
raisonne collectivement avec be si
évident et voilà faire connaître aux
consommateurs qui en ferme qui peuvent
venir ici visiter la ferme
en chiffres le lait d'ile-de-france ses
1200 vaches sur trois ferme et 10
millions de litres par an vendu 80
centimes la brique
il est collectée est conditionnée par la
laiterie saint denis de l'hôtel situé
dans le noir et le cinquième partenaire
on a l'assurance que le produit va être
mis dans les magasins va être valorisée
ensuite c'est à nous d'aller expliquer
aux consommateurs
pourquoi ce produit là eh bien il a de
l'intérêt pour lui en termes de qualité
produit en terme de deux prix en termes
ensuite de revalorisation au niveau 2 au
niveau des des producteurs de lait et
c'est tout l'enjeu que l'on a
aujourd'hui une tentative de réponse à
la crise du lait cette brique est
distribué dans 2 137 magasins en ile de
france
initié par intermarché le partenariat
vise à développer une nouvelle filière
régionale d'approvisionnement mais aussi
de mettre en valeur ces fermes
beaucoup de clients déjà savent pas
qu'ils avaient ferme dans 78 qui font du
lait ça c'est important de le savoir
ensuite ce sont des fermes qui sont
ouvertes au public donc aujourd'hui le
consommateur qui va être qui va être
curieux va pouvoir aller les visiter
pourquoi pas et aujourd'hui la qualité
du dès qu'on vend est irréprochable
donc on est très à l'aise sur le sujet
le lait d'ile-de-france est
exclusivement vendu par les
mousquetaires jusqu'au 30 septembre
par la suite ils pourraient être
commercialisés par d'autres enseignes
sur la première année pas moins de 23
mille briques de lait attendons pour une
future dégustation et prenons à présent
la direction à deux voisins le
bretonneux c'est une étape décisive pour
les habitants du quartier de la
bretonnière la future ligne 18 du grand
paris express ne passera pas sous leurs
habitations la société du grand paris
maître d'ouvragé a finalement retenu un
tracé alternatif c'était cet été
explications avec un nicolas
kirillovitch c'est un soulagement pour
une partie des habitants de
voisins-le-bretonneux la future ligne 18
du métro du grand paris ne passera pas
sous le quartier de la bretonnière un
temps pressenti par la société du grand
paris le trajet a été revue durant l'été
suite à la mobilisation d'un collectif
local
il n'était pas possible de passer sous
le quartier de la buire dernière
donc passer sous le groupe scolaire
passée sous les maisons c'était
difficilement envisageable donc la
commission denquête exprimer son avis
qui a été suivie par la société du grand
paris qui a proposé un nouveau tracé est
donc ce tracé il est acté dans la
commission denquête la ligne 18 passera
finalement sous les greens du golf
national à guyancourt pour la mère de
voisins-le-bretonneux alexandra rosetti
c'est une bonne nouvelle
elle se dit confiante pour la suite du
projet pour construire dont beaucoup
davantage tous le même contrôleur au
moins faire pour rattraper
à terme la ligne 18 doit relier
l'aéroport d'orly à versailles en
passant par saint quentin mise en
service prévue en 2030 pour un coût
estimé à un peu moins de 3 milliards
d'euros et urbanisation a toujours les
travaux de la médiathèque du canal de
saint quentin en yvelines sont terminées
et depuis lundi 5 septembre
l'aménagement du mobilier a commencé
située auparavant à quelques pas de la
médiathèque
le musée de la ville sera intégré au
rez-de-chaussée du bâtiment
nous nous sommes rendus sur le chantier
pour faire le point regarder
après les travaux le réaménagement les
pots de peinture ont laissé la place aux
meubles et au carton rempli de livres
le personnel de la médiathèque du canal
de montigny le bretonneux devrait
s'installer dans les locaux à partir du
12 septembre
la réhabilitation a duré plus d'un an
notamment pour améliorer la
fréquentation qu'on a commencé les
travaux au printemps dans la médiathèque
et dans le musée tel qu'il était prévu
au départ dans les locaux actuels
et assez rapidement on nous a demandé de
de modifier le
l'organisation des travaux pour
permettre l'installation du musée au rez
de chaussée de la médiathèque chaudière
système d'aération ou d'éclairage
tous ces équipements techniques ont été
rénovés dans un souci d'économie
d'énergie entre une journée en plein été
à midi et puis en fin d'après midi en
plein hiver l'éclairage extérieur n'est
pas le même donc il ya une régulation au
niveau de l'éclairage intérieur
donc on est petit capteur qui permet
effectivement de automatiquement en
fonction des limites extérieures d'avoir
une main de la rage intérieure calcul
est optimisé contrairement à la
médiathèque les travaux du musée se
poursuivre
il devrait se terminer entre le 15 et le
20 septembre sa surface atteindrait 400
mètres carrés
donc ça c'est un plan du musée là ici on
à l'accueil du musée on aura un petit
espace de projection
voilà en gros les expositions ça partira
de là
jusque là donc divisé en deux actions
expositions permanentes expositions
temporaires
l'accueil sera commun avec la
médiathèque
réouverture prévue pour le 16 novembre
prochain les préoccupations alliée à la
rentrée sont toujours là d'actualité qui
admis qu elle choisir comment trouver un
logement qu'ils activent des pratiques
et la rentrée à l'université peut être
source d'interrogation pour y répondre
lui vs qu propose aux étudiants un point
de rencontre unique installé dans le
hall de la maison de l'étudiant et cela
jusqu'au 30 septembre
des explications de delphine arnold
responsable du pôle de la vie étudiante
écouter le guichet unique pour fonction
de répondre aux questions que peuvent se
poser les étudiants à la rentrée donc
bah on peut avoir des réponses à des
questions d'ordre administratif donc
avec notamment l'assistance inscriptions
toutes les questions pardon concernant
les banques concernant les allocations
familiales le logement donc ça c'est une
question purement administrative et on a
aussi toutes les questions que peuvent
se poser les étudiants sur l'offre que
l'or et qui leur est proposée à la
rentrée aussi bien culturelles que
sportives
aussi bien au sein de l'université qu'à
l'extérieur nous avons également nos
partenaires bancaires qui sont présents
et les lycéens ont droit eux aussi à
leur lot de changements pour la rentrée
la semaine dernière le conseil régional
d'île de france a présenté les
nouveautés prévues pour cette année
au programme un ensemble de mesures sur
la sécurité dans les établissements la
lutte contre le décrochage scolaire et
la radicalisation c'est camille lambert
qui nous en dit plus avec la menace
terroriste cette rentrée 2016 ne sera
pas comme les autres pour les 500 mille
lycéens d'île de france le 30 août le
conseil régional a annoncé les
évolutions attendues dans les lycées
budget prévu pour ces changements plus
de 660 millions d'euros 10 millions
seront consacrés à sécuriser les
bâtiments un montant doublé par rapport
à 2015
ça va nous permettre de réaliser dans
130 clichés des opérations de
sécurisation alors cédé clôture à
l'entrée c'est de la vidéoprotection ces
défilés des signaux d'alarmé
etc etc ça correspond à des demandes
lycées pour faire face évidemment aux
risques auxquels ils sont soumis
nouveauté cette année l'expérimentation
d'un budget d'autonomie pour douze
lycées publics franciliens
une enveloppe de 780 mille euros est
mise en place dans les yvelines deux
établissements testeront ce dispositif
objectif donner plus de souplesse c'est
permettre aux équipes éducatives de
faire vraiment leur choix pour leur
lycée ils ont besoin de langues vivantes
supplémentaire ils ont besoin de cours
de soutien supplémentaires ils veulent
faire une spécialité sur le numérique
ils veulent faire une spécialité
internationale ils peuvent choisir la
région entend aussi lutter contre la
radicalisation en organisant des
conférences animées par des témoins du
terrorisme de parents de victimes de
mohamed merah ont accepté de participer
différentes actions culturelles seront
programmés pour favoriser l'ouverture
d'esprit on veut faire entrer plus de
culture est plus d'éducation artistique
dans les lycées d'île de france parce
que je crois que la culture c'est la
réponse à la barbarie et c'est aussi un
outil extraordinairement fort de
cohésion nationale depuis 2013 le nombre
de jeunes en décrochage scolaire stagne
aux alentours de 30 mille l'île de
france souhaite renforcer les actions de
prévention
valérie pécresse prévoit d'organiser des
assises du décrochage scolaire avec le
corps enseignant et des associations
les discussions devraient se tenir fin
septembre et cette dernière information
avant de refermer notre journal c'était
une promesse de campagne de valérie
pécresse
les tests salivaires devait être mise en
place dans les lycées franciliens le
conseil régional d'ile-de-france avaient
adoptée en mai le principe de financer
ces dépistages pour lutter contre le
décrochage scolaire au mois de juillet
dans une lettre adressée à la présidente
du conseil régional le préfet de région
a estimé que ce dispositif n'était pas
dans les compétences régionales en
matière de politique éducative selon
valérie pécresse les équipes
pédagogiques aurait instructions du
gouvernement de ne pas mettre en place
ces tests salivaires
elle dénonce un déni du problème par
l'état écoutez la le gouvernement ne
souhaite pas que cette politique se met
en oeuvre
moi je le mets en garde je pense que la
politique de l'autruche ne pas voir les
réalités ne pas voir qu'il ya des
addictions et des pratiques addictives
qui minent la réussite scolaire dans les
établissements empêcher les conseils
d'administration de prendre des
décisions librement je crois que ce
n'est pas extrêmement responsable de la
part du gouvernement c'est totalement
politique je souhaite un changement de
majorité à la tête de l'état et je
souhaite que le problème des addictions
et des pratiques addictives qui minent
la réussite scolaire soit pris en compte
et c'est à présent la fin de cette
édition merci de nous avoir suivis je
vous retrouve demain pour un nouveau
journal et vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur tv fil 78